yeah it's like Pharisee but on rogue
instead spitting out some fat yeah wrong
goes where you can I was right pulled
over he goes what are you getting this
information what you got
why didn't bring the [ __ ] diet that
was also make your job and I can't think
of the site yeah I get yeah but first of
all I love it it's like a steady Bravo
for infirmity people on that show
Hillary Clinton snorting babies and it's
like okay well just nobody's asking how
about we ask for a source on that you
know your [ __ ] and I'm a man of pure
mind and body and soul I take to our
fight which is fine all I said was the
gates goes into the third world and
every now and then he pricks something
and sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't and I'm right about that that
doesn't mean we don't need vaccines
that's right it means that I'm right
about that him and Melinda go on a
vacation to the third world would a
needle and just sit there and go are you
sure that's hats done I feel like your
sis is exactly how it can you show me
the technique underdeveloped country and
they go and they have like a fake
carnival okay and and and then people
are brought to them people are brought
to the carnival and everyone's like
having fun everything like that and you
know that thing where they throw you
know the carnival games they throw the
dart into the balloon yeah then what
happens is while you're not looking bill
takes the dart he goes I guess that's
what happens and sometimes it works and
sometimes I what's he putting in the kid
anything a vaccine to see if it works
and then sometimes a kid turns into a
werewolf sometimes that's what it is is
you have her facts lady where anyone
listen do you believe in pizza gate Tim
some of it this has been a very like
your science I have the facts bring
those I learned from Rogan because we
expect that's it I know facts matter
facts matter when you look at a guy like
me you go he's got the facts
that's what works first yeah yeah he's
got to stand outside of my shows I go
this guy's got the fastest sector that's
facts he's got that we make a statement
that's completely not true and this is
how we always get out of it okay my
father does this all the time he'll say
something that's completely provably
untrue about something's gonna happen in
the future we go why do you think that
he goes watch why then he's done like
what do you mean he goes watch it's a
way to win he wins and he's like he'll
be like leave that [ __ ] happen he goes
like this that business he goes that
business going out of business there we
go what do you mean they're killing it
every night he goes watch I walked into
another he's right into him hey Allen
wrote it was like dude what do you say
Bill Gates gonna is gonna hit you up man
you saying this [ __ ] you like I hope he
help me and Bill Gates are in a big
fight but no he's right about that I
should buy some of you but the reality
is I'm a comedian I'm here to bring
levity to a troubled world
yes that's reality also used fact and I
use facts and I know stuff because I'm a
smart boy yeah but you know
cross-reference what I see has to be a
Native American woman slash before you a
Chinese yes and the reality is I kept
saying to Rogan watch watch watch dude
no one that I grew up with his ever
spoken with the fact
no one's ever science always that's
always started the show yeah like we all
Saturday and Rogen used to say stuff and
then people would [ __ ] call dude we
get death threats over our corona talk
Jay gets him all the time they see me
Jay goes we're in so many death threats
on chironomid death threat death threats
Jay who about what about I'm not saying
that's all he's here about of it you get
death threats over that oh you met Jay
well yeah we're not saying that to be
careful though Dallas stealth
what are they saying just that we should
we hope you die I'll tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]